bah vraiment falloir bosser sur ton
envol armand potes parce que bon c'est
un peu m était sérieux est une balance
inclus dans la gueule là ça fait mal ou
défoncer la gueule ça va t'apprendre à
te fous de moi a essayé de me faire mal
un préfet sur la tête avec un caillou
waouh recule recule s'il te plaît
cervelle d'oiseau va cher visiteur de
filmsactu bienvenue chez moi ici mais on
a plein de dragon mais bon ils sont
gentils et ça sera tous méchants et
night appelé j'ai tout fait comment elle
s'appelait était vraiment méchant
chocolat déjà son nom ouais c'est ça oui
je partirai pas toi et moi tak tak tu
admirais ces deux messieurs voici un peu
comme les chevaux qui volent de toulouse
comme une belle et c'est ce qui va
graver à lessines et quand il va voir
mais l attention
mais c'est génial c'est en train de
voler pas besoin de dragon oui c'est
super c'est quoi ces arbres calcinés la
sérieux mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé
et d'émulation tellement gros
trop le soir etc est si ce pôle a kiffé
genre qui connaît plein de trucs sur les
dragons
laisse moi te montrer en plus je vais tu
n'as jamais vu
c'est tout maintenant est ce que je vous
connais non
mais moi mais moi si tu mon fils je suis
ta maman et enfin je veux dire en fait
j'ai sauvé tous les dragons j'ai pu
trouver tous les normands que ce petit
monde s'en fout je sauve tous moi
j'attends d'un grossiste et sa superbe à
damas même maman super problème parce
qu'il ya un problème de skills n'y aura
pas de grosse envie je te fais confiance
d'accord je sais que tu es un gamin est
totale à la mer en général c'est les
gamins qui s'en sortent le plus
ivry patrick amand ouais je vosges de
dragon oil on va leur [ __ ] une pâte et
julien doré